they're curating an image to appeal to
the party the foreign secretary holding
on to a clear lead in the polls casting
herself as a candidate to change the
course the former chancellor as the
electable underdog rishi sunak and liz
trust go head-to-head but as the pair
faced each other for the latest tv
debate an abrupt end to the show the
freedom and democracy
presenter kate mccann fainted in the
studio
she's understood to be fine now but the
program was taken off air
both candidates wished her well that any
focus on their pitches earlier in the
debate has been overshadowed we did have
that money available in the budget it
was a choice to break our manifesto
commitment and raise national insurance
i think it was the wrong choice to make
i spoke out against it at the time in
cabinet i still remain opposed to it and
i will reverse that rise i think what's
morally wrong is asking our children and
grandchildren to pick up the tab for the
bills that we're not prepared to meet
and truly if we're not going to have
this conversation that would be great
because you know i think we all knew
that we did a lot to support the country
through covid and i don't think anyone
thought that there wouldn't be a bill to
pay for that so the question is who's
going to pay that bill think about our
children and our grandchildren rishi
tsunak was less combative this time
before the sudden end with it perhaps
the chance for him to change the
narrative
it's in spin rooms like this that
leadership contests can be won or lost
and it was rishi sunak that needed this
evening needed this debate to close the
gap between him and liz truss but in the
time he had there was no decisive moment
to shift the dial do you think refusing
that can close the gap now or is it too
late i think a lot of people will
already have made up their minds there
are going to be hustings i don't think
they're going to be particularly highly
attended if i'm being honest
people may well watch the debates and
just look at what the interaction is
with the way the numbers are going and
the polls are looking she
just has to survive she has to get
through these debates and not make a
huge mistake
and it's a race that has been personal
rishi sunax clothing and schooling have
been raised in his old town some party
members still see him as cautious
continuity
i think on balance i i tend towards liz
truss i think you know he's the underdog
he's got something to prove uh he needs
to gain more traction no i'm sorry uh
it's rishi's the man a very capable man
who's got the intellect to do the job
they promise a lot
but you know we know what it's like
they're not going to deliver
some believe richie sunak is pitching to
the public more than the party ballots
go out next week time is running out if
he's to change the course of this
contest ali fortescue sky news